dans l'univers de la télé réalité et il
ya eu plusieurs grandes mode le culte du
corps l'apologie de la chirurgie
esthétique au plus récemment celui des
placements de produits sur les réseaux
sociaux à toutes les sauces mais
aujourd'hui bernard pivot semble avoir
hanté le corps de nos stars de la
télé-réalité puisqu'elles sont de plus
en plus nombreuses à publier un livre
mais que baudelaire se rassurent il
s'agit là d' ouvrages dans lesquels
après avoir tout montrer de leur
plastique à la télé elle décide de
raconter ce qu'il se passe à l'intérieur
à l'instar de jessica tivement star du
programme les marseillais et elle n'est
pas la seule à avoir cédé à cette mode
c'est le cas par exemple de carla moreau
et son guide pour se sentir bien la
villa et ses trois ouvrages sur sa vie
tumultueuse
amélie neten et son ouvrage sur les
acteurs jouent encore chanac res
candidate de la villa des coeurs brisés
qui il ya quelques semaines annoncé être
en train de rédiger son livre dans
lequel elle racontera son fascinant
parcours
lol autre star de téléréalité avoir
publié un livre à d'ixia révélé sur w9
dans ma revanche la jolie belge promet
qu'elle va révéler de gros secret sur
son parcours et sur sa vie alors les
stars de la télé réalité qui écrivent
des bouquins j'adore où c'est ridicule
[Musique]
affectionne avec nous vous n'avez pas pu
passer à côté les marseillais carton que
w9 est évidemment alors vous n'êtes plus
ensemble mais a dit xia paga je crois
que c'est le couple peut-être le plus
célèbre de la télé réalité depuis la loi
nageant edwards et lu quelques-uns
aujourd'hui je préparais vous nous
confirmez voilà et donc vous avez écrit
un bouquin cher à d'ixia la revanche ça
s'appelle maroc france voilà et
aujourd'hui on a le sentiment un petit
peu que voilà fini les marseillais les
bâches qu'on a vu des images nous vous à
tourner c'étaient les grosses pour les
grosses bagnoles allemande décapotable
les à se la raconter ça les tatouages
partout et là maintenant je reçois une
petite fille toute mignonne qui crée un
bouquin qui part notamment du
harcèlement scolaire pourquoi avoir
écrit ce bouquin parce que j'avais le
besoin de m'exprimer parce qu'en fait le
harcèlement scolaire c'est vraiment mal
vécue et je me dis qu'à l'heure actuelle
il ya des petits petite adolescente
pendant ces adolescents qui le vivent
et comme moi je suis médiatisé je me dis
que si je voulais c est faire passer un
message dans ce livre pour les aider les
consoler et trouver la bonne solution 20
c'est vraiment là sur le net c'est
vraiment dans un objectif
gg quand même réfléchi avant de le faire
parce que c'est vraiment j'avais faire
lâcher prise sur ce passé j'avais tiré
un trait dessus ge pour plus jamais
repensé pour
plus jamais reparlé ce que j'ai vraiment
mal vécu moi j'ai vécu vraiment
découvert seulement scolaire ou mérite
de en fait j'ai vécu un harcèlement
scolaire
donc avec un groupe de filles qui
m'attaquer physiquement et
psychologiquement mais un groupe un
autre groupe dans ma ville on ça veut
dire que quand j'allais à l'école j'ai
attaqué quand j'allais dans ma ville
pareil parce qu'en fait à mon bon elles
sont racontées des rumeurs sur moi et
dans le documentaire qu'on a eu cette
phrase comme un tournage et dire la
vérité tu dis aussi un moment que on a
tellement fait perdre confiance en toi
sur le physique et/ou que c'est de là
qu'est né un peu cette envie de faire un
peu été très belle mais très tôt un peu
de chirurgie esthétique ça ça n'a rien à
voir c'est autre chose encore et c'est
autre chose après chose
d'accord oui on sait quoi basse jusqu'à
il ya un moment où j'étais mal dans ma
peau et ouais et voilages après sa bonne
avant peut-être de sa ville le fait que
tu avais été critiqué les commentaires
des gens en france aient beaucoup
critiquant les réseaux tout ça tu peux
comprendre italia qui sort un bouquin et
puis pas de pardon mais on veut c'est
pas toi qui écris j'imagine non voilà
j'ai coécrit voilà on a pété un plomb la
plus vulgaire mans avant maintenant on
peut appeler ça un porte à un prêt prêt
après deux plus mal classés pas tous
beaucoup d'artistes absolument il ya des
hommes politiques doit pas se moquer
mais tu peux comprendre que ça puisse
faire un peu sourire tous deux quads hic
c'est qu'on a connu dans des bagnoles
avec les saints comme ça les matches
avec pagaal et m'achetait les
marseillais et tout d'un coup la petite
fille qui arrive en croisant les jambes
avec un bouquin sur l'enseignement
scolaire et qu'on dise c'est une blague
ouais mais après voilà je moi ça fait un
an que j'ai arrêté la tire et maintenant
et j'ai repris mes esprits et je suis
moi tu avais perdu ses esprits pour la
théorie
non pas du tout mais c'est qu'à un
moment donné avec on est sous le feu de
l'action on a tendance à avoir un peu la
grosse tête en fait tout ça et je
regrette d'avoir fait des marchés a non
pas du tout à non vraiment pas vraiment
c'est mes plus belles années
je suis aussi exactement et non je
regretterai jamais tous les deux que son
personnel a mentionné les interviewer
les chroniqueurs internet tout s'est tu
et sa durée quoi trois ans je dis merci
à vous présenter cinq ans tu dirais que
globalement tout ça en fourchette à peu
près ça te rapporter combien alors j'ai
pas envie je suis pas venu ici pour
parler de prix vous mais moi oui
alors qu'yves en rien du tout
une évocation giec mais réponse alors
auto question des mots justes
tu te bien que maintenant dès que tu vas
quelque part on est associé à paga oui
ça c'est un souci pour toi aujourd'hui
un souci oui pourquoi c'est un souci
parce que j'étais en vie dans ta tête de
passer à autre chose et même si j'oublie
bas dans la rue on parle de lui quand je
vais rester à lyon parents crient pas
gars c'est resté un ami ce lycéen a mis
à l'heure actuelle mais mais voilà c'est
vrai que c'est en défense quand envie
d'oublier quelqu'un et que tous les
jours tout le monde te le rappelle c'est
vrai qu'il ya aussi des barbus d'en
parler si tu me fais une liste des
choses à dire que si on est en train de
produire un documentaire avec freddy
ctia qui passera sur une chaîne
concurrente est justement a dit y a eu
la gentillesse dans le documentaire de
nous montrer son nouveau copain
absolument oui c'est si vous travaillez
beaucoup plus je n'ai pas vu je découvre
toutefois la plus regardée compte elles
seront pas avoir quelqu'un qui n'était
pas people qui vous pose une question
addiction mais voilà alors c'est
l'éditeur qui vous a proposé de faire un
livre ou c'est vous qui les proposait
l'éditeur on me l'a proposé
voilà alors je les remercie d'avoir
cette franchise ils sont chauds moi j'ai
été sous label ghost writer acer qui
créent des pros des jeux bruyants et
j'ai très bien comment fonctionnent les
éditeurs quand ils ont une idée
quelqu'un qui est bankable connaît la
télé ils veulent faire un livre pour le
vendre et on demande aux confins du
sujet pardon propose de juger ce que ce
sujet et ils nous disent surtout il faut
qu'il y ait de l'info ce travail là pour
qu'il la faut que d'un faux scénarios
cas l'info est monté en épingle pour
faire vendre de livres
donc tu es en train de dire et c'est
assez horrible que fait mon
l'enseignement scolaire on lui a mis
dans la bouche
balladur on l'a jeté deux cailloux et
enfin bouquet non je ne dis pas que ça
n'est pas arrivé jeudi que forcément il
faut faire un livre il faut tirer sur
quelque chose qui fasse vendre nos amis
à la presse se savent très bien qu'ils
électrique est très respectable avec ce
qu'elle réussit mais ça c'est comme ça
ici c'est la réalité si sa version de ce
qu'elles disent ah non c'est pas vrai
parce que y'a quoi dedans moi j'écris je
n'ai pas à l'auteur il le dit haut à
celui qui écrit mais tu peux pas
prochaine édition de chacun ce moment
fort c'est que sécrète story c'était un
petit peu pareil on disait aux gens tout
secret sera ça abbas était pâle lumière
balancer sa grand-mère est chaud c'est
jal et elle a des cheveux je passais
toutes mes addictions
réfléchi avant de le faire par le passé
des choses que je n'ai jamais parlé j'ai
eu du mal même
j'ai eu du mal à en parler vraiment je
pleurais à chaque fois que je rate en
question n'est ce pas tout simplement qu
est surtout à ces deux demandes de paga
parce que je la tue dictant encore amis
vous êtes amis mais il ya eu des moments
un peu pas très sympa je sais que tu en
parles dans ton livre oui avec pagaille
oui il ya un chapitre à ouaga où tu dis
quoi où je raconte comment en couple on
vit avec médiatisé d'y attiser comment
ça se passe réellement sottoli
mansouriah oui on s'est fait du mal tous
les deux avaient on a mal vécu en fait
on a vraiment mal vu que c'est bien si
on sert entamée sur nous mêmes on est
restés cloîtrés à la maison sortait plus
et on aime de regrets dehors de la télé
réalité
non tu en retrait oui c'est vrai oui
deux ans j'ai tout ça tu repars non je
pas les anges parce que voilà je reste
avec une autre voiture pendant qu'il de
base si je peux le refaire je referai
mais pour le moment c'est pas mon but
parce que moi c'est la musique parce que
c'est dans mon livre je parle de musique
de ma passion mais t'en veux pas les
tombeaux chaud le bal commence c'est ma
passion donc même si j'en vis pas je
m'en fout en fait tu vis de thé de ce
que tu avais avant et de tombes et et
d'influenceurs commence à mixer et elle
commence à mixer libye on a compris
qu'il aimait beaucoup mais myriam vialle
et tout macha mais faut quand même
reconnaître aujourd'hui il ya un vrai
business qui se fait autour de sa part
des gens qui voient là ont décidé de
décrire des bouquins pour voilà vendre
vendre des choses et faire de l'argent a
malgré la bonne cause le harcèlement
sexuel etc
autant je trouve que par exemple des
gens comme aurélie d'autres mon cas vers
une vraie histoire à vrais trucs à
raconter aussi un homme que c'est rien
ok mais non mais si je n'en ai aucun
donc voilà aussi je vois là je comprends
l'idée de myriam puis quelque part c'est
on vous appelle mon histoire et j'ai pas
envie de faire ça pour quoi
pour faire le buzz ou parce que c'est
une mode je suis désolé c'est pas parce
qu'on a fait de la télé qu'on n'a pas le
droit de sortir son livre on a chacun
on épouse myriam ouais là la reine a
raconté tu trouves le harcèlement
scolaire sais rien parce que c'est quoi
le harcèlement scolaire mais croise trop
maigri je te promets lui parlera je te
coupe pas mathieu qui a mis dans la tête
des gens que faire des livres de
témoignages sans un problème comme le
harcèlement a day allait aider les gens
vigueur mais pas juste après midi les
rivages et ont suivi par des petites
j'aime c'est un espèce de triade les
gens sont des livres écrits par des
médecins est déjà si elles connaissent
le sujet au sénat où mathieu n'est pas
tout en même temps chacun et chaque cas
est un journaliste que c'est un
témoignage
les amis j'interviens jeté vingt deux
secondes ce que je peux comprendre avec
mathieu c'est ce que tu peux comprendre
que si tu dis les gens nous suivent
mais si les gens le suivent suivent
alors je vais aller au bout du truc ton
bouquin il est touchant cela samo
scolaire mais ce que tu as montré
avancer les marseillais les grosses
bagnoles la chirurgie esthétique et 0,5
est-ce que ça c'est un bon exemple pour
les jeunes filles qui te regarde et qui
veut dire moins d'un mois du coup je
veux être tirés voir des gros seins et
une porsche
ça dépend la quantité dont j'aie jamais
montré une image de moi vulgaire je suis
désolé j'ai jamais à la vulgaire que
jamais votre histoire n'ont que ça à
dire que c'était moi quand je vois cette
jeune fille devrait alors je vois un
amour avec des mines comme tout quand
jour m'a montré les images des
marseillais j'ai vu que ce truc vous
dire que on fait une émission télé on
télé réalité6 se passe rien les jo on
décroche alors joueurs obligés de faire
les guignols a entre autres joué un rôle
non j'ai jamais joué de rôle j'ai
toujours été moi même et ça d'ailleurs
posé problème à la production parce que
j'ai toujours été quelqu'un de réservé
et mon harcèlement scolaire a fait que
mes premières émissions ça a été
compliqué quand j'étais la petite
nouvelle lecture monde était sur moi je
vais mal vécue par la production m'a
vraiment remis voilà et de fermer portes
aujourd'hui dans la musique dans toutes
vos salles de ferme les portes de
marseille est intimidant les écrits en
france la musique oui évidemment
certains mais david je tape tout le
monde à la bourre la gueule à dire que
on fait ça pour l'argent pourquoi parce
que l'industrie du livre on le sait tous
et vous êtes bien placé pour savoir paye
très mal moi mon premier livre j'ai
vendu presque 5000 exemplaires non mais
il faut savoir avant des chiffres dont
34 que d'acheter à peu près 20 milles
25000 euros ce qui est pour le nombre de
livres pas grand-chose d'accord pour ce
que ces gens là
annie avec les produits quasiment pas
grand chose donc on va pas dire que
c'est pour l'argent
non mais casse une image magali efficace
une image et qu'on tente justement qui
cassent une image suis très contente qui
montrent quelque chose et qui développe
autre chose que de la télé réalité parce
que ce sont des jeunes qu'on accable
constamment parce qu'ils ont dit qu'ils
n'ont pas grand chose à dire
mais finalement c'est des jeunes qui
quand ils font des livres vendre
énormément vivre et beaucoup oui mais
magali essaie de comprendre les gens
comment tu veux que quelqu'un qui
regarde la télévision se disent
d'un côté j'ai cette jeune fille qui
était une voiture de sport magnifique
avec un marseillais
on entend en influence heuzé je te vends
des trucs des crèmes des machins donc
tout ça on est dans la superficialité
les plus totales et puis tout le suivi
comme tous un bouquin c'est la toussaint
ce scélérat et qui font de la télé
réalité qu'ils n'ont pas d'histoire
c'est juste l'histoire des fois beaucoup
plus toujours c'est vous encourez choisi
pour beaucoup mais c'est comme si tous
étaient des gens justement qui sont pas
canalisé ki moon la téléralité parce
qu'à la base il sont pas canalisé donc
justement ils ont une histoire qui est
différente des autres et qui mérite
d'être entendue donc j'ai des infos on
peut pas tout
[Applaudissements]
boutin il nous reste quinze secondes
l'udc
mais oui c'est un peu le syndrome vilain
petit canard c'est pour les enfants de 8
10 ans 12 ans qui sont qui sont tristes
et cetera qui se disent moi je me fais
cru et j'ai des boutons je me faire seul
et c'est si on se disait à 25 ans je
serai jolie et je serai célèbre ça leur
donne de l'espoir d'enterrer sa console
quand même imaginer bizounours film mais
ça je dis ce que malheureusement la
france est comme ça on est tous pareils
si demain je vends un bouquin baisse ne
serait pas crédible si magali demain dit
allez tous à l'expo grand palais bon ça
serait grotesque et jeudi si quelqu'un
devait l'arrêter sur un bouquin un peu
sérieux sur des choses je pense est
malheureusement bien sûr qu'ils le
chocolat les gens veulent voir ce qui ce
qu'ils boivent et les ventes jessica
tribunal a vendu 60 7000 bouquin
sébastien bayet n'ai rien vendu 500 du
sien vous êtes la preuve j'ai dit
mathieu vous êtes la preuve mais le
produit tout à fait ce que brice juste
des mollets pour toi en retard je te
laisse du coup mon show qu'est ce que tu
veux dire la caméra et là tu as dix
secondes d'essai à tous avant ton livre
pourquoi faut l'acheter pourquoi la
racheter parce que si tout simplement il
ya des petites filles des garçons qui
vivent le harcèlement scolaire
j'espère qu'ils vont retrouver le
réconfort dans mon livre retrouvez de
l'espoir et surtout pas ce livre en fait
je les mêmes dédier à mes harceleuse à
celles qui vont harceler toutes mes
autres retrouver une telle arrêtées
bientôt non pas du tout encore signé non
mais dans le